we're looking at the universe's oldest
and most distant galaxies in more detail
than ever before everywhere we look
there's galaxies everywhere NASA on
Tuesday released the first set of full
color images captured with the 10
billion dollar James Webb Space
Telescope more than six months after it
was launched into orbit decollage
liftoff from a tropical rainforest to
the Edge of Time itself James Webb
begins a voyage back to the birth of the
universe
the first images that NASA has given us
really are meant to demonstrate Webb's
incredible capabilities in terms of
scientific observations but how did Webb
capture these first of their kind images
and what could they tell us about the
universe and life beyond our planet
[Music]
named after a former NASA administrator
the James Webb Space Telescope is 100
times more powerful than its predecessor
the Hubble Space Telescope which has
been orbiting Earth and taking pictures
of distant stars for over 30 years much
of Webb's power comes from its massive
primary mirror which is more than 21
feet wide giving it more than six times
the light collecting area that Hubble
has a telescope sensitivity basically
how much detail it can see depends on
the size of the mirror area because the
more light a telescopes mirror can
collect the more able it is to see
objects in finer detail that are farther
away web is situated about 1 million
miles away from Earth where it can get a
clear view of these details it also has
a sun shield that protects it from
external sources of light and heat like
the sun earth and moon because Webb is
operating much farther from Earth than
Hubble Is Where ultimately does have
higher observing efficiency Webb also
see ease the universe differently many
telescopes are designed to primarily
capture visible light which represents
only a sliver of the spectrum of light
emitted by stars and other celestial
objects in contrast web captures a range
of infrared light that is invisible to
the human eye but makes up much of the
light that comes our way from the
universe we're looking at some of the
sort of faintest stars earliest stars
and earliest galaxies in unprecedented
detail and web will also help us probe
these planets outside of our solar
system known as exoplanets scientists
can study these exoplanets by measuring
the intensity of light at different
wavelengths and turning it into a
graphical representation like this
exoplanet Spectrum released Tuesday
that's really what enables us hopefully
to sort of peek into the atmospheres of
these exoplanets and ultimately maybe
find one with a similar atmosphere to
ours
scientists are specifically interested
in the presence of water or methane
because those could indicate there was
or is life on those exoplanets one of
Webb's main scientific objectives really
is to help us look for signs of life on
other planets outside our solar system
images like this Deep Field observation
captured by Webb will also help
scientists study the development of
celestial objects in the universe over
time they help us resolve the details of
fainter objects like stars and galaxies
that were born much closer to the Big
Bang than some of the other ones that
perhaps Hubble can see
in the 32 years since it was launched
Hubble has taken more than 1.5 million
photos and helped extend our
understanding of the universe while the
web mission is expected to continue for
20 years scientists are hopeful it will
provide new insights about the formation
of stars galaxies planets and perhaps
the presence of life
NASA has many telescopes but I think
James Webb for various reasons has
really captured the Public's attention
and Imagination and I feel like people
are really rooting for this telescope
and what it can tell us
[Music]